schluss es reicht alles auf den mist ist
mist das ist das credo des dreigespann
fester kern journalistin und koch
website gründerin spitzenkoch pascal
haab jahrelang rezept entwickler beim
ältesten vegetarischen restaurant der
welt dem hilton sowie fotograf silva
müller für den ästhetischen genuss
zuständig das trio ist dabei ein
kochbuch zu kreieren titel lief tim roth
vom blatt bis zur wurzel analog der
bewegung alles von geschlachteten tiere
zu verwerten
auch von dem was in der erde wächst soll
in zukunft radikal alles verputzt werden
inspiration gibt es auf dem markt was
kann man mit lang verschmähten gemüse
teilen bloß alles anstellen
mit
radieschen erbsen und anverwandte haben
in den letzten jahren enorm an
stellenwert gewonnen
gemüse ist mehr als beilage
das hat auch die gehobene gastronomie
erkannt sie trumpft mit bisher
ungewohnten variationen geschmäckern
texturen fast ein neuer lifestyle
kapuzinerkresse wurzel die demnächst
israel herz ohne viel leid und für mich
mega schön gefunden um ihr aufgeschaut
radieschen letter salat naheliegend und
doch für viele neuland unglaublich
witzig das ist für die nyt wo lukas
scharf dass das element in die ganze
bitterstoffe bisher ist also kein
vorschlag klingt nach kulinarischen
vergnügen
obwohl die blätter ein wenig bares dich
sind auch das rütli krauter lebt den
steilen aufstieg mixa stadt kompost
früchte und reiße mich dazu walla ein
smoothie der perfekte mineralstoff
lieferant
weiß ja was grundsätzlich skrynnik nass
und kalt thailand und das ist der weg
eine weile dort und vor dem her ist
sicherlich erzeugt deshalb gespannt
sieht sehr gesund aus delikat das epson
schadet scheele die hülsen sind essbar
ungemein geschmacksintensiv das leidige
detail ein cs heute trotzdem die gruppe
aus zeitmangel überfluss überdruss
unwissen vor lauter wettrüsten
schnipseln und schnetzeln sind uns
unbeschreibliche köstlichkeiten abhanden
gekommen
und das ist eigentlich der hauptpunkt
vom ganzen und dann aber den kleinen
teil zum zeigen dass man überhaupt nicht
zum großen fest das haben wir in der
schweiz eigentlich ist
dieser idee wird hier und jetzt die
krone aufgesetzt
wir werden zeugen des mais h experiments
ist das nicht eine struppige
angelegenheit
exotisches gemüse fast alles ist möglich
fast
es gibt praktische grenzen
experimentieren sowie das größte das
muss dass man der häufig neu bewerten